ya eu aussi le clash thierry ardisson
m'enfin qui a fait une petite vanne sur
matthieu delormeau franchement mathieu
il le fracasse tout le temps dans les
émissions et vous vous n'êtes pas
contente parce que forcément quand on
est amoureux on voit pas les choses de
la même façon c'est ça oui moi c'est
tout simplement un coup bas et alors je
sais pas si mal
oui c'est un coup bas et moi je ne sais
pas si mathieu a dit du mal des
émissions de wimbledon à chaque fois et
ce que j'ai vu en tout cas j'ai bien vu
l'émission de thierry ardisson et ont
bien vu à quel point il avec lâcher et
franchement il n'y avait rien à voir il
avait rien à voir dans le débat soit pas
pourquoi il est derrière la question
quand il veut clash est très violemment
il sait le faire là c'est franchement
une piccione franchement la réponse du
berger à la bergère
alors attendez le maire gérard 10 au tir
à dix on a réagi lundi je n'ai pas de
l'inimitié pour matthieu delormeau même
fait des petits pics dans mon émission
tout le temps et là sans tomber sur lui
il n'y a pas de haine particulière
envers mathieu delormeau
il n'y a aucun antécédent et pour vous
dire que ça même si mathieu est mon ami
voilà il le fera qu'à sa g sur la
dernière fois il y en a mis plein la
gueule il est voilà donc oui balle
orange est le meilleur ami de laure baud
je le rappelle de mathieu c'est pas faut
essayer il n'a pas de haine particulière
quand on dit être anglais oui c'est pas
la première fois voilà une fois il avait
dit sur moi de façon totalement gratuit
kevin et recevez nabila lui a dit
pourquoi vous avez planté votre votre
fiancée thomas nous aurions mieux fait
de planter un couteau dans le dos de
jean michel maire monsieur jouer rien
faire et trouve les alors à jouer rien
fait alors nous ont fait plus de vannes
alors le nom du banal de étrangler les
gens raymond manière que nous ici on dit
plus rien est-ce qu'on plante pas des
couteaux toute l'année en version la
france défendra sans même pas sur les
plateaux leurs plantes des couteaux on
n'arrête pas de 20 jeux c'était léger à
l'arrivée c'était mon fils giral et oui
alors vous non plus
tu n'y arriveras je suis désolé mais
c'est non voilà une des raisons qui m'a
compte